[Music]
hi everybody welcome to today's session
how can machine learning help my career
today i'm joined by three ml
practitioners
as we discuss um how and why
you should get started in machine
learning
first i have jyoti nuclea i'm the
principal product manager
for aws deep composer jyothi could you
tell
our viewers a little bit more about your
machine learning experience and
and your journey to aws yeah definitely
it's a pleasure to be here michael
and as michael stated my name is jyoti
nukula and i'm the
principal product manager for aws deep
composer
i look forward to teaching you all a
little bit
more about how deep composer can expand
your machine learning skills
and to talk a little bit about my
background
uh i've been with the aws ai devices
team
for the past four years and have been
with this team since its inception
and prior to deep composer i had the
amazing opportunity to work on aws deep
lens
which is another edge device that allows
developers to learn about machine
learning uh and computer vision through
hands-on
and uh fun uh projects where your
uh where the projects run at the edge
and um and you can take your ideas from
an ideation stage into an implementation
stage
and i uh got to experience and work with
some amazing colleagues
uh as part of that machine learning uh
experience
it's great to have you jyoti and we look
forward to learning a lot more about uh
aws deep composer
um next we have juve chan who is joining
us from singapore
and he actually graduated from the
udacity machine learning
nanodegree machine learning engineer
nanodegree program
duke could you tell us a little bit more
about your uh career path and machine
learning and
a little bit more about how you got
started
hi everyone thank you for that
introduction michael
my name is jew chan i'm an ai developer
focused on ai chatbot development
in the financial services industry based
in singapore i graduated from
three udacity nano degree programs in
deep learning
machine learning machine learning
engineer as well as
intel hai for iot developer
so i'm uh aws certified i'm aws
certified in the machine learning
specialty
and i'm also a winner of the aws degree
certainly
at the aws summit singapore in 2019
uh i'm really excited and honored to
share my machine learning journey with
all of you today
yeah thank you michael oh yeah it's
great to have you
and you'll be the main person i'm
leaning on to learn a little bit more
about
uh udacity and how i can get started
learning from the comfort of my own home
and last but not least we have rahul
shiresh
the software development manager for the
ai ecosystem at aws
uh raw could you tell us a little bit
more about your machine learning journey
and
and what you're going to speak about
today absolutely michael uh thank you
for having me
uh like michael said i'm an engineering
manager at aws
and i'm currently part of the aws
devices arc
where our primary goal is to make
machine learning
available for every developer so as part
of this endeavor
my group has been involved in launching
multiple projects over the last years
including
deep lens deep racer and now deep
composer which jyoti is going to be
talking about in more detail
prior to joining aws i was working in
amazon devices
where i help build and architect a
number of smart home products such as
echoloca and cloudcam
i have been involved in machine learning
for many years in my career
and today my primary interests lie
in working at the intersection of cloud
computing and machine learning and i
find this area super exciting and i see
so much opportunities in the future it's
great to have you right
and to really kick us off i'm actually
going to lean on your expertise
um so i think it's only right that if
we're going to spend today talking about
machine learning to learn
about machine learning at the most basic
so could you give us a brief history of
machine learning and
and why is it such an emerging field
today absolutely
and this is a great question michael and
before we go into what machine learning
is
let's take a step back and look at what
artificial intelligence means
so artificial intelligence is or ai as
it's commonly called
is a very significant branch of computer
science
where the machine learning the machine
learns the ability to do things that
normally is reserved for humans and
their intelligence
that's the reason it's called artificial
intelligence machine learning is a
specific subset of artificial
intelligence where
the computer learns to predict or do
things without being explicitly told to
do so
so instead of giving a bunch of rules to
your computer
your computer rather learns your machine
rather learns to make the predictions or
decisions
for example you may provided like 10 000
images of cats and dogs
and tell them like hey these are the
images of cats and these are the images
of dogs
but you don't really tell how a cat
looks like a dog look like
looks like and then you feed it through
your model
and your machine learning algorithm then
learns to differentiate between cats and
dogs without being explicitly told to do
so
so this is a classic example of how
machine learning works
uh one thing i'd like to call out here
is that machine learning until recently
was just limited to a few major tech
companies because of the amount of
compute and
uh uh compute resources and data that
was needed
however with the advent of cloud
computing machine learning has become so
much more commoditized and easy and
accessible
for every single company be it a startup
or a researcher
all you need to do today is plug in apis
and you get
all the benefits of machine learning to
you as a result machine learning today
is proliferated across every single
industry be it
finance retail health care and whatnot
this is like a really exciting time to
be in machine learning nice so it sounds
like all
everybody on this call uh got into the
field at the right time
and as raoul stated uh machine learning
is a growing field
um in the corporate space according to
the world economic
forum um there will be an estimated 58
million jobs created over the next
or by 2022 in in the field however
currently only 300 000 people are
qualified so
looks like it's the time to get into
machine learning
um and so i guess my first question
since i'm here with three ml
practitioners is how did all of you guys
get started with uh
machine learning um ro could you could
you kick us off
absolutely so i got into machine
learning and computer vision
or during my grad school and i took a
number of courses to help me
with the basic foundation of computer
science as well as machine learning
subsequently i was an engineer at
qualcomm
where i worked on the team that built
optimized
machine learning and computer vision
algorithms for your mobile phone
so that gave me an opportunity to
take complex computer vision and machine
learning algorithms
and make it work on a small device where
you know the power is constrained
where you have to make it fast and you
should make sure that
it gives a good experience when you use
the phone that made me understand a lot
about
how machine learning works and how that
is tied to the compute resources on your
system
after moving to amazon i had the
opportunity to take the same machine
learning project product however
or the same machine learning ideas but
build services with it
at scale one example is cloud cam which
is amazon's first
home security camera so as part of this
project
we we are able to use a lot of benefits
of machine learning and computer vision
to make sure that
your home is secure through the security
camera similarly after moving to
aws i've been involved with a number of
projects i started off with deep bracer
now i'm also involved with deep lens and
deep composer
where we take machine learning and make
it available for all developers
so this this has really made me
understand
how how much machine learning is
proliferated
in today's world and how important it is
and i'm really passionate about taking
these ideas into the hands of every
developer
so it must be cool for you uh sitting on
a call with with somebody who actually
has become a champion
uh in deep racer in juve
absolutely absolutely
i'm really i'm really happy that you is
here
so yeah dude let's uh i think the deep
racer connection is a uh is a great
segue so
um could you tell us a little bit more
about how you got started with machine
learning and
and um hopefully give us some tips and
tricks to
also win a few aws deep racer races
yeah thank you michael thank you rahul
yeah so my uh five year
five years ago when i was working as a
cloud developer
i wanted to develop my career into a new
career path
uh with a much stronger machine learning
focus
so it has since then i started my
self-paced machine learning education
with um online courses such as uh
udacity
websites books open source projects
hands-on labs we should focus on data
science and machine learning
and today i'm still continuing on my
machine learning journey
so i finally got the opportunity to move
into
more ai development career in 2018
so which is working as an ai chatbot
developer
which i has been working until present
so i believe my my continuing
machine learning education has
definitely played a big part
for my career progression from from
being a
traditional full stack developer club
developer into
into my new role in ai development
so yeah so i really appreciate that all
right
uh jyothi over to you uh could you tell
us a little bit more about
um your how you got started with machine
learning
so uh my journey with machine learning
started
a few years back in my undergrad
i did my engineering in biotechnology
where
part of my project was into next
generation sequencing
and that's when i came in
in connection with one of the professors
here in the u.s who was also working on
using machine learning
and therefore i collaborated with him
on using machine learning to help
identify uh the uh
biological age of a person from their
genomic analysis
and that was my introduction into
machine learning
and post that i worked at 3d systems
uh where i was developing 3d printers
uh for consumers and and while we look
at 3d printers as a hardware device
there's a lot of software and machine
learning
intelligence that goes into it
especially
to make sure that a part or any image
that you give to a 3d printer needs to
be
assessed by the printer to ensure that
it prints appropriately using the
material and also give an error to a
user if it thinks
the material is too thin or too thick uh
for the design that they have provided
so
there was quite a bit of machine
learning involved there
um and i used some of those techniques
to actually print
my own uh uh drone that i could um
fix electronics into and then fly around
um
for my own hobby um
yeah so that was my fun way of getting
hands-on with machine learning and after
i joined
amazon i kind of got to put my
passion and my hobby together
into in into the same space where i'm
very excited about new technologies next
generation cutting edge
[Music]
solutions to help our customers and
i was it was at the right time right
moment i was with aws deep lens
and uh it was the starting point where
we were looking at how do we democratize
machine learning
to ever to all all developers and make
it really
easy for everyone to get started with
machine learning
and after uh being and working on awsd
plans i moved on to deep composer so
it's
it's been a really interesting journey
and a pathway to
where i am today that's awesome jothi
and i think uh you're you're the right
person to ask this question
so um as somebody who has
no prior machine learning experience or
no prior developer
being experienced um what's what's the
best way for me to get started with
email
yeah so you reach the right person as
you said
so at aws machine learning our mission
is to
make machine learning accessible to all
developers irrespective of their skill
levels
and so our aws edu devices portfolio
was designed specifically to make sure
that developers
with a variety and diverse set of
experience can get hands-on with
machine learning regardless of where
their machine learning expertise is like
you could be a beginner you could be a
data scientist an advanced practitioner
there is always something uh that you
can get hands-on with our aws edu
devices
so for example let's say you are
thinking about starting with
computer vision maybe you have a fun
hobby that you want to
uh try it out but start with aws deep
lens
um and start with a few projects that we
recommend in the console
and then you can get your way into
experimenting
for uh reinforcement learning you can
start with aws jeep racer
um where you you not just learn about
reinforcement learning but you get to
play and win uh
some cool leagues like what you did and
for uh if you're interested in the
complex cutting edge
technology of generative ai i would say
start with aws deep composer where
you you get to learn about generative ai
while you're composing music
in a very fun hands-on medium
so raul jolte told us the way to get um
kind of hands-on experience with machine
learning through the aws
educational devices portfolio but if i
wanted more of a classroom experience
are there options for that absolutely i
think udacity
aws machine learning scholarship program
would be a great setting for you to
learn about machine learning
the aws ml foundations course will help
you develop
develop skills basic skills about object
oriented programming
including writing clean modular and
readable code and it will also introduce
you to machine learning on aws with
generative ai and aws deep composer
as a result upon completing the course
you'll be awarded a certificate of
completion
you will also have the opportunity to
take uh if
you will also have the opportunity to be
eligible for a scholarship program here
so the top 325 students will be
selected for scholarships to one of
udacity's most prestigious
nanodegree programs the aws machine
learning engineer program
uh anyone who is 18 years 18 years of
age or older is encouraged to apply
you must enroll in the program complete
the foundational course
and submit the assessment quiz by july
31st 2020
to be considered for the scholarship all
right so i have about a little over two
weeks to
to follow in juice footsteps
absolutely so juke could you tell me a
little bit more about um
the the the machine or the ml engineer
nanodegree program and and what was
really beneficial about that program to
your
ml journey hi uh okay so as i graduate
from the program
i've learned new skills and reinforced
existing skills in
software engineering best practices such
as how to
write stream code as mahi mentioned as
well as more importantly the
machine learning workflows from building
training
validating and deploying
machine learning models to production
with aws
machine learning services uh i myself i
really like the
um the hands-on projects in this
machine learning nano degree program
where i i get to learn how to use like
aws machine learning
services such as amazon search maker
notebook instance
amazon switchmaker python sdk
etc to build uh train uh deploy machine
learning models
with different machine learning
frameworks such as
pytorch uh scikit-learn tensorflow etc
uh so like for example like uh for from
this program
i've uh i've built uh built and deployed
a sentiment uh sentiment analysis
uh model for to uh for analyze the
sentiment of a piece of
movie reviews text and i also get to uh
build a plagiarism detection model from
scratch
so uh so in addition to that uh
uh i also get to uh choose
uh my own uh real real problem to work
on and
and implement the solution with machine
learning methodologies and workflows
which i learned from this program
for the capstone project so um
so i i did choose from i i did choose a
a real problem from like some of the
from
candle competition yeah so
uh for uh so i was able to apply
these skills that i learned from here uh
to my career as well
for example like i've learned the skills
from here on how
to uh able to build and improve my uh
the
natural language understanding model for
the ai
for the ai chatbot which i've been
working on at my work
nice yeah thanks so i really look
forward
to continue to apply these skills from
that learn from here
and i'll really love to try to build
some
open source projects uh uh using amazon
machine learning services all right that
was a uh
glowing recommendation so i know i'll be
enrolling as soon as we wrap up this
webinar
um and then i guess my last question for
you guys
um and then we can we can start with
raul what do you think is the biggest
opportunity um for ml
as we go forward i think the in my
opinion
uh ml i'm not gonna single out any
single
area or application because like i said
before i think
machine learning today is in a very
interesting phase where
science has progressed a lot and due to
all the cloud computing advances it's
getting more and more
accessible to a lot of people so in my
opinion the biggest area is just the
proliferation of machine learning into
every industry and
it's no more going to be restricted to
big companies or you know
teams which have scientists in them
today
i think machine learning is something
that every developer uri can
think about machine learning and easily
plug it into our application
and this could have a wide-ranging
benefit to the society and people using
it but you know
individual developers can absolutely
make the choice to use
machine learning wherever they want and
that's the beauty of it it's so
easily available today that it can make
a widespread impact in
pretty much any industry you think about
yeah so
juve as somebody who is already taking
full advantage of the opportunity uh
ml is presenting um what do you think is
the biggest area
for growth of ml in my opinion i think
the biggest opportunity
uh with machine learning going forward
uh
would be ai for healthcare for example
like how machine learning can
help to develop and effective vaccine
to fight against like today's pandemics
in a
much faster and effective and
cost and also cost saving besides uh
i think like uh the combination of ai
and robotics uh for ai health care
can be used to help the spread of
pandemics uh more effectively
through like automated disinfections in
the public areas
and also like maybe on the area of
quarantine
monitoring yeah that's my opinion thanks
and we'll wrap it up with uh jyoti and
what do you think is the biggest area
for growth of uh
in machine learning as we look forward
sure
um i would say machine learning is
already all around us
um for example if you have uh ever said
alexa turn on my lights you have used
machine learning
if you have used maps to navigate from
place a to place b you have used machine
learning
so machine learning is already around us
um
and i think the value is in um
in the fact that more and more research
is being done
to make models that are leaner that can
run
on devices that
don't necessarily need heavy computing
power
uh lean devices or lean models i would
say models that can run at the edge
and uh the other aspect is that
as these models grow more robust you
you start seeing uh companies applying
machine learning for
product development product design uh
and even
for uh making uh machine learning models
itself robust like what generative ai is
being used for
uh is to create synthetic data that can
make your machine learning model more
robust like for example
if you're if you're an energy company
and
oil and gas or energy company and you
wanted to
create a model that can detect both
positive and negative leaks
like positive would be no leak but then
a negative would be when there are leaks
um and so you would want something where
your machine learning model is able to
now uh detect uh
and and be more robust similarly
you you want to have your
model more robust across different data
representations
and you would want to use generative ai
to create those synthetic data sets to
make your model robust so i would
um i would say that machine learning
its ability to detect patterns and
identify and and
get as close to as how we look at uh
we look at analyzing objects i think
it's it's a very growing and booming and
advancing field
all right so by all accounts everybody
here would say
that um right now is the best time
to get started with uh with ml and you
can get started
um with udacity or with the aws
um educational devices portfolio
uh and it's in your hands to to really
get started so
so that wraps up our our roundtable
session um and now i'm
going to hand over the reins to raul and
uh jyothi to to give you guys a uh
an exclusive aws deep composer demo
thanks michael um let me walk you
through the aws deep composer con
console i'm super excited to
be giving this uh demo here for our
udacity audience
as part of this demo we'll go through a
couple of algorithms we have a
generative ai
and an auto regressive
cnn algorithm available uh in the
console
so i'll walk you guys through it um also
there
there is learning capsules for those of
you who want to
dive deep into the concepts of
generative ai
and learn its technique there is
learning capsules available in the
console
and once you but once you create a
composition don't forget to participate
in the chat busters challenge that is
currently running right now
uh where you get a chance to top the
charts and win some prizes
uh so that's something everybody can
participate in as well so i will
show you how to create a composition and
then how you can
submit that composition to chatbuster's
challenge
let me share my screen now so i'm
already on
the aws deep composer console but if you
want to log
in you can go to console.aws.amazon.com
make sure you're in north virginia
region if you're not you can
[Music]
choose the panel to choose
not virginia region since deep composer
is available only in the north virginia
aws region
so this is the music studio in aws deep
composer
as you can see we have provided a couple
of sample input melodies if you want to
uh get started and you're not comp let's
say you're not comfortable with playing
on the keyboard you can use some of the
sample input melodies
like me i i'm bad at playing a piano so
i'm going to just
save everybody here and just use the
sample input melody today
and on to the right you can see that
there are different parameters that are
available
so you have two technic generative ai
techniques that are available one is uh
gans which is the generative adversarial
networks and the second is the
autoregressive
now you may be wondering what is gans
what is auto regressive how are these
two different
and to help people get started with
these concepts
you we've added learning capsules you
can access the learning capsules by
using the left navigation pane
and go to learning capsules and you can
see that there are two capsules
available
that you can use each of these capsules
provides bite-size
concepts that you can use to learn about
these
techniques and understand the generative
ai concepts in detail
so now let's get started with going back
to the music studio
i'm going to choose this generative ai
technique called autoregressive once you
take this
regressive technique you need to choose
a model
and there's only one model available
which is auto regressive cnn
buck so i'm going to choose that model
but before i get there let's
hear the input melody twinkle twinkle
little star as it stands
[Music]
well so that was our twinkle twinkle
little star
now coming to the advanced parameters uh
you have
four different parameters that you could
tweak
uh for your uh generative ai model
so the first parameter is the maximum
input nodes
that the algorithm can remove and so
this is based out of percentage so let's
say
um if you say 100 of my notes it can
remove
then uh the model is going to
identify all these uh places in the
um in the in the uh melody that it can
uh that's probably not uh similar to
your bach
composition and and try to
tweak that similarly you have maximum
notes
that the algorithm can add and in this
case
uh the the algorithm is going to
automatically decide
based on based on the tune if
it needs if there are places in there
that it can add to make your composition
sound more bark-like
and sampling iterations is the number of
actions
that your model can take and your
creative risk
is in terms of how uh
how deviate what sort of deviation you
want in your
uh in your composition one is a very low
risk and six is a very high risk in
terms of
the diversity in in the composition
itself
so i'll probably do a couple of
iterations across these and you can see
the difference
so first i'm going to just change one
note here some
i i wouldn't say um 100 i would probably
say let's
choose 80
and then i'm going to keep all of this
at zero so you can
just see that difference and i'm going
to keep the creative risk at one because
that's not going to really impact
and now i choose enhance input melody
and now i have
my my new composition right here so you
can see that some of
some of the uh notes here have been
tweaked
than what it was before and this is the
algorithm that's
trying to make it sound more back-like
let's listen to it
[Music]
you notice some difference but not a lot
of difference because we just tweaked
one
parameter here so let's say we keep that
at 80
and then i'm going to um increase
the maximum number of notes so let's say
i'm going to make
it 70
and i'm going to keep the creative risk
the same
notice how um notice how
the pattern over here the notes are
going to change
and so you can see that the model did
make some changes
minor changes to the notes so i'm going
to now
[Music]
composition
so then now let's try to increase
the sampling iterations which is the
number of actions that your model can
take i'm going to make it
about 90 here i'm going to say enhance
input melody
there you go you can see it's introduced
a couple of notes in here
that uh can make it sound more back like
so
i'm going to play the composition now
[Music]
okay now let's increase the creative
risk to maybe
four
and enhance our input melody further
let's listen to it now
[Music]
so now so this is just one iteration
this is just one time
i've tried different things the beauty
is only when you
try different uh ranges different
parameters you experiment with it and
that's when
um you can see how the algorithm uh
works
with uh with your input melody to make
it more
uh soundbark like so now let's say for
example i want to reduce
the sampling iterations um further down
to maybe just say 40 i'll keep the
creative risk the same
i will keep maybe maximum
notes to remove i'll increase it to 90
and then keep this at 80
and then make this move bring this to 3
so you can see
it's i'm i'm really experimenting here
there is no um one one
sure short way to get um get to uh how
you
uh want your composition that's that's
how uh two people can start with the
same input melody and it'll still be
different after a couple of iterations
so i'm going to enhance my
input melody
let's listen to it
[Music]
do
okay i want to further make some changes
here
i'm going to further make this probably
i'll
increase this to 50
and i'm going to enhance this
[Music]
getting there but not there yet i'm
still going to go ahead and keep
enhancing it
until i find it comfortable
let's try this again
[Music]
let me do it a couple more times with
the same parameters
[Music]
so i'm just going to pause here for a
second and then go ahead
just in the interest of time go ahead
and enhance it
[Music]
further
so you can see that it sounds it no
longer sounds like what it started it's
sounding more and more like
it's coming uh closer to a bark symphony
and so i'm going to go ahead and enhance
it further
[Music]
listen
there you go that's an that's an example
of how
um with repeated experimentation and
uh some parameter tweaking you can get
your composition from
uh where it started to do something that
is inspired
and let's say i like the way it is as
um as it is and let's say i want to
submit this to
uh chatbusters um i will
make a note of this composition 36
i will go to chat busters
so the current chat buster challenge is
back to the future
where you use the auto regressive cnn
technique that's the technique that we
use in the demo
to generate compositions in the style of
bach and so i want to submit
my composition since i'll choose submit
a composition
and i'm going to choose an existing aws
deep composer composition
which is the comp 36
i'm going to choose that and
you need to sign into soundcloud and
then hit submit
and this will um automatically submit
uh to the playlist
on soundcloud and we'll have the winners
announced on july 31st
so i'm really excited to see the
compositions that you
create while you're learning about um
generative ai and as i said if you want
to learn about the concepts behind
autoregressive and gans you can use the
learning capsules
and get through to understand
the various concepts
so that's what i have for the demo here
over to you michael all right thank you
jyothi so
um i hope you guys appreciated that walk
through through aws deep composer and
take full advantage of uh
the opportunity to be your own producer
and uh participate in the chartbusters
challenge
i'm excited to see what you guys uh all
come up with and i'll definitely be
adding the best songs to my playlist and
jew raul jyothi i i really wanted to
just thank you guys all for taking time
out of your busy schedules to to come
speak with um
our viewers today a little bit more
about how they can pursue a career
in uh in machine learning um
and so everybody be sure to enroll in
the udacity aws ml scholarship program
and complete the foundational course uh
so that you can take the assessment
in the hopes of getting one of 325
scholarships to the nanodegree program
thank you michael thanks michael thanks
everybody
bye take it easy
you